la séance est reprise allez allez
monsieur le ministre si vous voulez bien
vous asseoir
et ben alors
nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi de financement rectificatif la
sécurité sociale dans le Sénat est saisi
en application l'article 47 1 alinéa 2
de la Constitution dans la discussion
des articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement
2169 à l'article 13 monsieur le
rapporteur
le 1018 qui le présente
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à supprimer la ligne 45
les mots n'étant pas assujetti à une
durée d'activité définie par un
employeur en effet la retraite
progressive est un dispositif encore peu
utilisé mais qui permet de réduire
immédiatement son temps de travail sans
diminuer dans la même proportion ses
ressources et en continuant d'augmenter
ses droits à la retraite la nécessité de
l'accord de l'employeur limite
considérablement l'accès aux dispositif
de retraite progressive l'article 13 en
cas de le refus de temps partiel de
l'employeur lorsque la quantité de
travail souhaité est incompatible avec
l'activité économique de l'entreprise
l'appréciation de la compatibilité et de
la quantité de travail et des besoins de
l'activité économique de l'entreprise
rend de facto inapplicables accès à la
retraite progressive nous estimons que
la retraite progressive doit être un
droit pour les travailleurs qui
s'imposent aux employeurs j'en profite
pour saluer l'ensemble des salariés leur
famille qui ont manifesté ce matin et
pour certains cet après-midi et pour
d'autres après-midi et leur dire que la
parlementaire que je suis malgré les
recours au procédures et la surdité du
gouvernement m'oblige à continuer la
bataille pour le retrait de cette
réforme merci merci avis de la
commission
avis des favorable à cette position
monsieur le ministre même avis merci le
2170 monsieur le rapporteur rédactionnel
monsieur le ministre le 4033 qui
représente monsieur Fabien gay non oui
non ah pardon pardon pardon madame le
notre amendement vise à préciser que
tout refus dans l'employeur est motivé
par écrit si nous souscrivons à l'idée
d'élargir le bénéfice de la retraite
progressive à l'ensemble des salariés le
dispositif est vidé de sa substance par
la possibilité laissée à l'employeur de
refuser aux salariés le bénéficie le
bénéfice pardon de la retraite
progressive il faudrait faire du passage
à temps partiel dans le cadre de la
retraite progressive un droit opposable
faute de quoi le dispositif ne
bénéficiera qu'à une poignée de salariés
au risque d'alimenter une logique
profondément inégalitaire avec la
retraite progressive il n'y a pas que la
question l'intensité du travail il y a
aussi celle de la liberté de choisir le
moment et la manière de partir en
retraite au regard des conséquences sur
le montant de la pension le recul de
l'âge légal à 64 ans contraint vraiment
les les personnes à travailler donc
comme on l'a dit plus longtemps c'est
particulièrement injuste enferme les
travailleurs des travailleurs dans un
dans un carcan c'est à dire ils ont le
choix avec une retraite trop petite et
de devoir en plus s'user davantage à
travailler l'aménagement du temps de
travail en fin de carrière ne peut être
limité à un refus de l'employeur sans
explication aux salariés pour ces
raisons nous demandons à minima que ça
soit stipulé par écrit j'ai bien un
minima parce que vous l'aurez compris
toutes nos interventions visent à
demander le retrait de cette réforme et
nous sommes solidaires des
manifestations qui ont lieu partout dans
le pays aujourd'hui encore merci avis de
la commission
il est satisfait cet amendement madame
Cohen
voilà donc avis défavorable parce que
satisfait c'est le droit actuel
celui des ministres
merci
quatre amants de discussion commune le
40021 qui le présente Madame Cohen
on vient de enfin je viens de on peut
dire qu'il est qu'il est défendu et
j'adore quand même la logique qui
préside à anneau débats c'est-à-dire on
est en train de faire comme si de rien
n'était on commente des des amendements
qui en fait sont virtuel puisqu'ils
n'ont pas été retenus et on arrive à
nous dire que ils sont satisfaits qu'il
faut passer assez moi je trouve que
c'est lunaire
le 2171 rédactionnelle monsieur le
rapporteur
merci le 318 qui le défend
UE
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
je ne pensais pas que cet amendement
présenté par David hassouline arriverait
si vite c'est amendement il vise à
prévoir le la consultation du comité
national consultatif des personnes
handicapées avant que le gouvernement ne
prenne un décret sur les conditions de
cumul de la pension d'invalidité avec
une retraite
progressive nous avons présenté cet
amendement dans le but
d'enrichir et de préciser le texte mais
il ne pourra pas être soumis au vote
puisque comme vous le savez maintenant
par cœur je pense vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement
d'ailleurs le journal Le Monde de cet
après-midi titre
les débats anesthésiés au Sénat
et bien nous ne sommes pas anesthésiés
ni par le chloroforme de l'article 47-1
de la Constitution ni par le 44.2 ni par
le 44 3
ni par vos amendements qui n'avaient
pour but que de faire tomber nos propres
amendements ni par l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat ni par le 46 10 si je
ne me trompe pas de numéro nous ne
lâchons rien nous ne lâcherons pas les
Français et nous continuerons à nous
battre contre ce projet de réforme des
retraites merci Monsieur frérot
le 2920 madame Lubin c'est amendement
porte sur la formation professionnelle
mais moi je voudrais profiter
de
par un autre rapporteur d'abord que le
la retraite progressive moi je trouve
que c'est un dispositif intéressant et
il le sait à la condition que ce soit
encadrée que l'on veille à ce que les
salariés ne perdent ne perdent rien s'il
vous plaît c'est compliqué ne perde rien
en matière de de revenus à côté
c'est-à-dire que le complément bon voilà
par contre je suis
je ne suis pas du tout favorable au
cumul emploi retraite
parce que surtout lorsqu'il est présenté
surtout lorsqu'il est présenté comme une
alternative à l'emploi des seniors ou
comme une solution pour l'emploi des
seniors ce qui était le cas au début de
l'annonce de ce de ce projet de loi
pourquoi parce que le problème de
l'emploi des seniors c'est justement
qu'à partir de 55 ans ils n'ont pas
d'emploi donc ça n'est pas le fait qu'il
cumule que ceux qui arrivent à la
retraite cumulent avec un emploi qui
apportera de l'emploi au seniors on est
bien d'accord donc
je considère que pour la plupart du
temps la plupart du temps ceux qui sont
obligés de cumuler un emploi avec une
retraite sont ceux qui ont des retraites
extrêmement modestes d'autres le font
par passion de leur métier je ne le dis
pas mais ça n'est quand même pas le le
la majorité on va dire des salariés qui
cumulent retraite et
retraite et emploi voilà ce que je
voulais dire et vous et vous dire
Monsieur le Rapporteur que je sais que
vous êtes passionné par votre par le
sujet mais je trouve que ce n'est pas
tout à fait loyal de nous asséner tout
ce que vous nous assénez parce que nous
ne pouvons pas répondre or nous avons
des arguments
à vous opposer voilà la passion je crois
que nous sommes quelques-uns à la voir
et nous avons des arguments à vous
opposer voilà merci merci Madame Lubin
je vais donner la parole aux rapporteur
alors pour aller non pas dans le sens de
Madame Lubin mais monsieur le rapporteur
merci de ne pas poser de questions
puisque par définition les élus ne
peuvent pas vous répondre
dommage monsieur le rapporteur j'ai
effectivement un sens du débat qui est
bien différent vous dire quand même que
vous dire quand même que même si
certains prétendent que le Sénat est
anesthésié les sénateurs ne sont pas
endormis et en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne cet amendement c'est
effectivement un amendement qui demande
un avis par rapport au par rapport au
décret qui doivent être pris donc il
aura le même sort que celui dont nous
avons débattu ce matin quand on cumul
emploi retraite je pense avoir exprimé
l'avis de la commission alors
d'amendements précédents mais nous
aurons l'occasion peut-être à travers
d'autres amendements de repréciser la
position de la Commission
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président le
Gouvernement est favorable de 1171 du
rapporteur et défavorable trois autres
amendements pour les mêmes raisons
merci
monsieur le rapporteur 2572
rédactionnelle
coordination c'est le Ministre merci
amendement du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre le rédactionnel
merci
Madame ponts et mange le 31 39
merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement nous nous soutenons
beaucoup le dispositif de transition
emploi retraite quelle est la retraite
progressive à la différence du cumul en
poireaux traite c'est nous pensons une
transition vertueuse la retraite
progressive est un dispositif essentiel
pour le maintien en emploi des seniors
et la prise en compte de l'accroissement
de leur vulnérabilité face au risque
dont les risques psychosociaux de fait
selon les chercheurs servent volcov et
Corinne Godard beaucoup de seniors se
maintiennent en activité professionnelle
à condition de disposer d'aménagement du
temps qui leur conviennent la sortie
d'un système contraignant d'horaires ou
de rythme est alors pour ces personnes
une condition pour ne pas sortir de la
vie active donc afin de prévenir
l'augmentation des risques et de
permettre à un maximum de personnes de
profiter de la retraite progressive il
est important en conséquence que l'âge
d'accès au dispositif soit maintenu
correspondent à un âge cohérent avec
l'accroissement de la vulnarie
vulnérabilité c'est pour ça que puisque
vous repoussez l'âge d'ouverture des des
droits de deux ans sans modifier l'accès
au dispositif qui est possible toujours
deux ans avant l'âge d'ouverture des
droits le présent projet de droit de loi
pardon constitue de fêtes un frein pour
de nombreuses seniors qui vont devoir
attendre 62 ans pour en bénéficier aussi
nous souhaitons
excusez-moi
voilà
par ailleurs oui je reçois un instant un
message de notre collègue Paulo sans
tout Parigné et c'est encore ce j'espère
que la traduction sera fidèle vous avez
décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre vos mains
nous ne sommes pas du les Français non
plus ils sont dans la rue aujourd'hui
nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne les
lâcherons pas j'espère par Outlook ma
tradition de ton peuple est exacte c'est
terminé madame foncé et merci de faire
en sorte que finalement les SMS ça
fonctionne bien allez
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur le 3139 la solution qui a
retenu la commission puisque nous
proposons de faire un dispositif qui
serait commun à tout public mais on
avait envisagé cette solution avec une
différence c'est le droit actuel en fait
par rapport aux droits prochains que
propose le gouvernement donc avis
défavorable
le 2173 rédactionnelle
le 2174 coordination
le 2175 coordination le 2176
coordination le 2177 rédactionnelle 5
amendements identiques
au Gouvernement est favorable surtout ça
en revanche le texte ne précise pas que
l'employeur doit motiver son refus aux
salariés l'employeur pourrait en
conséquence adresser un refus aux
salariés sans justifier de
l'incompatibilité du temps partiel avec
l'activité économique de l'entreprise
voire sans même donner de justification
aussi afin de s'assurer de la
réification du dispositif l'amendement
précise que l'employeur doit motiver son
reçu son refus pardon aux salariés par
écrit
c'est le centre de qui le défend madame
madame la Présidente pardon merci
par notre collègue de midi donc il est
défendu par notre collègue Cabanel merci
c'est
le suivant le
2360 madame vermeiller pardon oui
monsieur le Président amendement
identique de Michel canevé il est
défendu merci
ensuite madame Lubin le 2642 ah pardon
pardon pardon monsieur Tissot
le ministre mes chers collègues à mon
tour de m'adresser à vous et de vous
dire que vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute on vous l'a dit
plein de fois que nous laissions la
retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites locaux alizés nous ne sommes
pas dupe les Français n'ont plus nous
lâcherons rien nous ne lâcherons pas et
c'est donc pour ça que je vais vous
présenter cet amendement le projet de
loi encadre et la possibilité de refus
du temps partiel de l'employeur dans le
cadre de demande de salariés souhaitant
bénéficier de leur regret de progressive
en vertu des règles introduites
l'employeur ne pourra refuser le temps
partiel que lorsque la quantité de
travail souhaitée est incompatible avec
l'activité économique de l'entreprise et
devra adresser son refus aux salariés
dans les deux mois or le projet de loi
ne précise pas que l'employeur doit
motiver son refus aux salariés
l'employeur pourrait en conséquence
adresser un refus aux salariés sans
justifier de l'incompatibilité du temps
partiel avec l'activité économique de
l'entreprise voir sans même donner de
justification or pour que la mesure
introduite par le projet de loi est une
réelle efficacité en pratique
l'amendement précise que l'employeur va
motiver son refus aux salariés par écrit
Merci monsieur merci chers collègues le
3441 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président ce projet de
loi donc en cas de les possibilités de
refus de temps partiel en permettant à
l'employeur de le refuser ce temps
partiel lorsque ce serait incompatible
avec l'activité économique de
l'entreprise sans aucune justification
pour que cela ne soit pas totalement
discrim discrétionnaire je vous propose
par cet amendement d'imposer que
l'employeur motive son refus aux
salariés par écrit il y aura donc un
écrit c'est un moment que nous avons
reçu de la part des organisations
syndicales pas très respectées de nos
jours il est vrai mais nous tenons à
déposer parce que nous respectons leurs
paroles et surtout leur revendications
cependant j'avais un autre amendement il
a été déclaré ircevable comme beaucoup
vous allez me dire qui allait encore
plus loin et qui proposait de supprimer
la possibilité pour l'employeur de ne
pas donner suite à cette demande parce
que c'est souvent la condition de
maintien en emploi du travailleur senior
ou tout simplement la sauvegarde quand
même de sa santé selon l'adresse en 2020
le dispositif de retraite progressif
concernait 24000 personnes ce qui est
vraiment une honte il est selon les
termes de l'adresse très marginale
voulons-nous vraiment que plus de
personnes puissent disposer de la
retraite progressive à temps partiel qui
est un dispositif vertueux de transition
entrant l'emploi il a retraite voilà une
solution simple supprimer la possibilité
pour l'employeur il a ce salarié de ne
pas donner suite à sa demande de rester
dans l'entreprise de maintenir son
emploi
en passant à temps partiel c'est ne pas
c'est ne pas lui permettre de se reposer
enfin se reposer parallèlement au
travail après une vie entière de labeur
donc voilà nous aurions aimé discuter de
cette mesure mais nous ne le pourrons
pas par ailleurs Paulu sans tout Paris
me dit que j'ai très bien traduit
ce qui voulait vous dire
alors c'est quand même l'essentiel
monsieur le rapporteur c'est cinq
amendements identiques
oui effectivement la commission
également c'est penché sur cette affaire
là parce que dans le les propositions
gouvernementales la réponse le refus en
tout cas de l'employeur doit être motivé
voilà alors là vous prêt vous vouliez
préciser une réponse écrite et motivée
où on avait pas retenu mais bon ça peut
ça peut être effectivement une précision
pourquoi pas écouter moi je vais
demander l'avis au gouvernement pour
avoir sa position par là mais dans la
première réflexion de la commission des
affaires sociales c'était une réponse
défavorable
mais ça ne peut pas être oral non plus
alors monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président le
gouvernement considère que la précision
est utile c'est un avis favorable et
nous avons intégré ces amendements dans
le texte qui sera soumis au vote unique
de votre assemblée
très bien allez allez allez allez
le 430 qui représente monsieur Fabien
gay monsieur gay vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
sommes pas d'accord monsieur le
Président et il y a un affrontement de
classe aigu ici qui joue dans
l'hémicycle comme dehors mais peut-être
qu'on pourra se mettre d'accord tous
ensemble sur une chose le Sénat n'est
pas un îlot complètement sorti de la
société et moi je veux saluer les
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
se mobilisent pour la septième journée
consécutive qu'on ne se réforme unique
des retraites et il faut leur dire une
chose vous pouvez vous moquer de nous
nous méprisez nous maltraiter tentez
nous bâillonner de nous piétiner mais je
vous le dis une chose
si si on le vit comme ça écoutez on peut
entendre ce que nous avons à dire vous
pouvez faire tout cela mais nous
resterons dignes et debout jusqu'au bout
pas pour nous pas pour nos petites
personnes mais pour les centaines de
milliers de personnes qui sont en train
aujourd'hui même de se battre partout
dans la rue à Paris comme dans vos
villes et villages et nous continuerons
jusqu'au bout il reste 641 amendements
jusqu'au bout a donné nos arguments
jusqu'au 20e article parce que nous
faisons nous pas pour nous-mêmes mais
pour toutes celles et ceux qui se
mobilisent et qui sont majoritaires
alors que vous êtes une poignée
aujourd'hui à vouloir cette loi et je le
dis et je finis une question à monsieur
le rapporteur il pourra pas me répondre
et m'interpeller mais je lui pose
comment va jouer la CMP à 14 dans une
salle mercredi prochain il va falloir
nous dire et l'expliquer non pas à nous
mais aux françaises et aux Français qui
se mobilisent parce que si vous pensez
que vous allez régler cette question
politique à 14 minoritaires dans une
salle et que tout le monde va avaler ça
vous vous trompez et nous resterons
mobilisés jusqu'au retrait de cette
réforme je vous remercie monsieur le
président
allez on va pas créer de problèmes vous
reconnaîtrez monsieur Fabien je suis pas
sûr vous ayez vraiment défendu
l'amendement mais bon on va considérer
que oui et que la vie du rapporteur
négatif
allez-y monsieur rapporteur
je donnerai la vie du rapporteur quand
même sur un objet important puisque là
c'est l'inverse dans les dispositions
c'est une suppression des dispositions
qui prévoit que le refus par l'employeur
de la demande de retraite progressive du
salarié doit être soit justifiée tout à
l'heure on dit que elle doit être
justifiée motivée et par écrit et là non
ça doit pas être c'est l'inverse
voyez-vous alors la gauche unie se
désunit me semble-t-il à travers cet
amendement et simplement sans répondre
sans répondre
à mon collègue je rappellerai simplement
que les conclusions de CMP sont ensuite
présentés à chacune des assemblées quant
à l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Sénat
tu avais du gouvernement sur
l'amendement
merci
et je l'entends même pas la VR et oh je
n'entends même pas la vie du
gouvernement ou du rapporteur si tout le
monde parle en même temps alors reste
merci Monsieur gay de rester calme ça va
avancer deux amendements discussion
commune le 400039
le 4039 je vous en prie oui monsieur le
président
six manifestations historiques
90% des actifs opposés à la retraite à
64 ans et votre seule réponse est le
mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale et surtout mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats qu'il refuse de recevoir
mépris envers les salariés envers les
Français votre votre projet n'est pas
légitime retirez-le notre amendement
celui que nous allons présenter
maintenant visa supprimé l'alinéa 161 de
l'article 13 je suis étonnée que la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat ne propose pas de supprimer cette
disposition alors même que le rapport
prévoit je cite la commission regrette
toutefois que l'âge d'éligibilité au
dispositif soit porté de 60 à 62 ans
considérant que la retraite progressive
doit constituer un outil de prise en
compte des carrières terrible en
permettant la légende de la charge de
travail de l'assuré en fin de carrière
elle a adopté un amendement 2168 du
rapporteur prévoyant le maintien de
l'âge d'éligibilité à 60 ans pour les
bénéficiaires actuels de ce dispositif
comme pour les nouveaux donc si la
majorité sénatoriale est favorable au
dispositifs de regret de retraite
progressive il faut créer les conditions
pour permettre son application effective
dans le sens de cette sens de notre
amendement qui supprime la possibilité
pour l'employeur de refuser la retraite
progressive à temps partiel en raison de
l'incompatibilité de la durée souhaitée
par le salarié avec l'activité
économique de l'entreprise quelles sont
les raisons de cet amendement merci en
discussion commune le 4041 qui
représente oui pardon
merci monsieur le Président six
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et pire mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le car si
nous souscrivons à l'idée d'élargir le
bénéfice de la retraite progressive à
l'ensemble des assurés le dispositif est
vidé de sa substance par la possibilité
laissée à l'employeur de refuser aux
salariés le bénéfice de la retraite
progressive s'il juge que le temps
partiel demandé est incompatible avec
l'activité de l'entreprise autant dire
que ça va fermer pas mal de portes il
faudrait au contraire faire du passage à
temps partiel dans le cadre de la
retraite progressive un droit opposable
faute de quoi ce dispositif ce
dispositif pardon ne bénéficiera qu'à
une poignée de salariés et je pense
notamment aux cadres qui sont par
exemple souvent au forfait pour les
métiers à forte pénibilité cette
aspiration à la réduction du temps de
travail avant d'arriver en retraite est
plus que justifiée la pratique des
entreprises consistant à licencier les
seniors peut être contrecarré par le
bénéfice de la retraite progressive
encore faut-il garantir aux salariés qui
en font la demande leur garantir qu'il
puisse avoir une possibilité de
contester devant les conseils de
prud'hommes le refus éventuel de leur
employeur je vous remercie merci avis du
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements de
discussion communes
4039 propose de supprimer le que le
employeur ne puisse pas refuser le
dispositif on peut comprendre que pour
des dispositions de bonnes conduites de
l'entreprise et puis y avoir des
conditions de refus donc c'est pas la
position qui cartonnée la commission
quand au 4041 là aussi ça rejoint
l'amendement qui avait été
précédemment
soutenu pour lequel la Commission avait
émis un avis défavorable et Monsieur le
Ministre un avis plutôt favorable à
savoir que le refus de l'employeur doit
être motivé par écrit donc avis je
dirais défavorable sur les deux
amendements pour l'instant
même avis
le
2178 du rapporteur est un amende de
correction d'une erreur de référence
c'est ça
avec du gouvernement favorable
favorable à toute la série des
rédactionnelles ou des coordinations
donc sur le 2179 coordination
2180 coordination
2180 coordination également
2182 rédactionnelle et j'en arrive au
président gontar pour le 255
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
déjà apporté ma totale solidarité avec
l'ensemble des Françaises et des
Français qui défilent partout en France
aujourd'hui six manifestations
historiques 90% des actifs opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et votre seule réponse
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris le
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et surtout le mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qui
refusent de recevoir mes prix envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le
l'amendement que je m'apprête maintenant
à défendre et qui a été déposé par le
groupe écologiste vise à demander au
gouvernement un rapport je sais ce que
vous pensez des rapports mais ça me
paraît important suivant la promulgation
de cette un rapport excusez-moi qui
présente les différentes options
législatives ou réglementaires
permettant la diminution de la durée
maximum de suspension entre la demande
de l'équitation de la mise en place d'un
cumul emploi retraite si l'article 13 de
ce projet de réforme des retraites vise
à rendre le dispositif de cumul emploi
retraite créateur de droit il faudrait
également faire en sorte de réduire le
délai de carence avant la mise en place
d'un cumul emploi retraite demande donc
au Parlement de remettre un rapport pour
étudier les options qui permettraient de
diminuer le temps d'attente entre la
demande de liquidation et la mise en
place de ce dispositif de cumul emploi
retraite nous souhaitons tout de même
réitérer notre avis sur ce dispositif de
cumulant par la tête qui n'est pas une
solution puisqu'il est très inégalitaire
et en effet nous l'avons déjà dit à de
multiples reprises ce dispositif ne
bénéficie majoritairement qu'aux
personnes qui ont occupé un emploi de
cadre sont en bonne santé et ont une
pension de retraite correcte ce
dispositif va précariser encore un peu
plus les retraités qui ont de petites
pensions et pousser les plus pauvres à
travailler au-delà de 64 ans encore une
fois la priorité du gouvernement et de
la majorité des satural ne devrait être
plutôt de corriger les inégalités de
carrière qui concernent majoritairement
les femmes et d'augmenter les pensions
de retraite qui sont largement
insuffisantes cet articlement campus de
forcer les Françaises et les Français à
travailler deux ans de plus le
gouvernement refuse d'augmenter les
pensions et pousse les Français les plus
précaires à travailler au delà de 64 ans
merci monsieur le Président avis de la
commission
la Commission a gardé ce délai de six
mois pour que le dispositif de surcool
soit plus incitatif que le dispositif de
cumul emploi retraite donc à vider
favorable
merci avis du gouvernement mais ma vie
l'amendement
2057 rectifié bis présenté par Bruno
retailleux de ses collègues a été retiré
[Musique]
je
voilà je je pressentais je pressentais
un mouvement de joie
je remercie une partie voilà très bien
allez
c'est comme ça donc l'amendement 2057 a
été retiré non mais monsieur gay
chacun fait oui non mais bon allez bravo
vous vous en rêviez il l'a fait voilà
allez
et nous passons et nous passons en
conséquence allez allez on se calme à la
discussion de l'amendement 1369
de madame la Présidente billon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la loi du 9
novembre 2010